it's crazy too because your legacy is
like cemented at this point and you've
kind of gone from like being like a guy
if you really weren't a like a Houston
or Texas hip-hop fan you just knew about
Trey because it was like the guy in Te
who runs Houston it's like the guy you
don't want to [__] with in Texas you
know what I'm saying um and like you
know fast forward 15 years you're like
very much a community leader you're very
much like when you think of like you
know when when I think of what you and
Mr Rogers were doing out there Shout Out
Mr Rogers um just crazy just like not a
lot of people would roll their sleeves
up and like actually do the work to like
help their neighbors I I'll tell people
or or also not just that by the way like
I've seen you post if some sort of
situation happens MH so we do a lot um
to touch on the stuff with Rogers like
people don't really realize the
time relief gang right yeah they don't
realize the time and everything that we
went through and dealt with you know
from Health to family to just we dealt
with a lot trying to do what we could do
for everybody you know
and that that's the part that that's
always going to be implanted in both me
and him but you know to the rest of
where they don't really they only see
what we showing that that was only 20%
of what we do you see what I'm saying
like you got to you're not doing it for
the wrong re we only doing it when we
show it we show for awareness because it
gets people more help and it also plants
seed to show people that they can do
things to help people you know like it
everybody think you got to be
millionaires to help people and that
ain't the case sometimes don't even take
money it may take the time or just the
ear you know and like nobody seeing of
sleeping in cars not being able to to
eat for days or or you know just
different stuff like it's a lot that
came with that man but we dedicated to
and even to this day I'm some happen I'm
one of the ones that's going front I was
going to say can you give us like a
random example cuz like I've seen it a
bunch like if there's a situation where
something bad happens to somebody or you
know there's an unfortunate thing like
you'll pull together your resources
you'll post about it you know can you
give me a situation in which you just
helped somebody that because I I think
some people who don't really necessarily
follow you they know about what you guys
did in the hurricane but you guys do
stuff all the time for people oh man
it's it's too much to name um they
talked to me earlier about Miss Martha
which was the 77 year old lady they took
to jail I mean the lady they took to
jail for $77 she was like 80 something
years old y you know we I got there for
her um start working to rebuild the
house raised like 40 50,000 um done a
lot of different stuff for um you got
that
um the man that they they showed me they
was trying to take his land in Texas
elder man went out there spoke up for
him um RP to the homie Canal I don't
know if you see the dude who he had less
than a few days to live he was on
hospice and I was saw him recently he
passed away right I was the Mexican dude
right yeah well no he's Indian oh okay
okay I saw the food Community Pages
posted him and he just passed away maybe
two days ago right so when they reached
out I was one of his um one of his
favorite rappers I believe it's
paig let we just give it 8 to 10,000
followers and um but then them his
biggest thing that he wanted was to be
able to get to the people and motivate
them you know to show people even with
him knowing his time was coming still be
grateful I just the the video that
really like was crazy to see was I I
think it was a video he posted it the
day before he passed or two days before
he passed and he was barely hanging on
but he was still very like yeah and I
you for me for me to take him
from to eight or 10,000 people being
able to see who he is to almost 2
100,000 in the matter of a couple days
help spread his message Man spread his
message like no other you had people
shout out to the rock you had people
everybody from all across the world
reaching out you know what I'm saying
so it it's just so many different things
that I do you know you had the you had
the recent hurricanes and uh in the
Mississippi you know I'm I'm out the
front line with that it's just it's so
much different stuff that we do yeah for
sure yeah yeah then you know we still
fighting for ban Taylor we still want
Justice for that um special [__] you to
Daniel Cameron and you know we still
keep it going yeah it's crazy too
because if you think about like you know
some of the activism that came came out
of the
pandemic you know it felt at a at a
certain point in time like it was just
trendy for some people but you gotta but
I'm but I let me finish my thought what
I was going to say was and then and then
you'll see people like cord day you'll
see people like my son people like you
like and it's like yo this is not just
because it's popular to post a black
Square on Instagram or it's popular to
spread awareness cuz what because we're
stuck in the house so so the thing with
that is people don't really understand
again they only know what they see they
don't know lives are at risk every day I
don't know if you know you know me my
son we move yeah I'm going to get to
that too we we moved to Kentucky we were
living there wow so imagine being
followed by helicopters you you getting
random unmarked CS Following being shot
at whether it may be tear gas different
stuff um you know we've been we've been
through a lot man I'm talking about any
anything when anything can go the same
man Daniel Cameron just for us showing
up to his house had us arrested tried to
give us felonies but you can't do
nothing to the the officers that cold
blooded killed Banna Taylor crazy you
see what I'm saying like but I I I tell
people when it come to stuff like that
anytime we leave out the house [__] it's
not guaranteed we coming back that [__]
just as serious as the street life when
you dealing with going against crooked
officers the cops are biggest gang in
the and they really what's crazy is
police literally move like a gang say
I'm not going I'm not going I'm I'm a
realistic person I'm not going to
pending on all of them because even
times when we were arrested and stuff
like that you have officer P aside like
man I respect what y'all doing I hate it
got to be this way yeah I I would say
this like obviously most cops are good
but I just mean in terms of like the
culture of police there's Unwritten laws
that they had they follow it is very
much you know so crazy be funny right
like when people talk about the streets
and the industry snitching right right
mhm officers feel the same way if you go
tell on them that's what I was going to
say the same way like if a cop snitches
on another cop that cop out yeah you
Outcast yeah so it's it's definitely the
same [__] it is definitely the same [__]
it is crazy I wonder um I I have you had
any sort of like cuz you feel like the
type of person who could run for office
and win never I don't I don't do
politics have you ever met with like you
know I you know I've seen Killer Mike
meet with um the governor of uh Georgia
who I know is more of a conservative guy
have you ever tried to meet with the
it's it's nothing you really can do
coming through Texas and not know who I
am so I came across just about anybody
it's been
times rather than even say their names
there been times some of the people at
the top of the ladder reached out to to
to talk or to try and come move through
the
town um and when me to pull up and I
just won't I just stand on principles
you know if it's something I believe in
cool if not no now what I do now is I
try and give people the knowledge like I
gave a lot of people that know you can
actually
be in jail and and vote you know what
I'm saying like it was just it was
different things that could be done and
then a lot of people you know their
mentality was like what I need to vote
for my vote don't count but when I start
helping them to
understand matters if you feel it count
or not the way we win is to get the
right people in office you see what I'm
saying cuz if we ain't voting we letting
the people who going to [__] us over at
all times sitting office and whether
they run up money on Texas for for
whatever reason Texas has gotten a lot
closer in terms of it it's I know it's a
conservative state but it also is like a
state that I feel like a lot of people
are are are willing to look at other
ideas if you will you go to a place like
Austin Austin is like a a a blue City
and a red State you know what I'm saying
like Austin kind of feels like it's its
own like it's its own like it's like you
going to a whole other place when you're
there man Austin is always it's that's
always been a lot of any of us from
Houston that's always been music- wise
one of our biggest fan bases um Love
Austin shout to Yellow Rose great
establishment as far as the industry
itself it's a dope place because they
love music I I look at Austin as when
you go to a lot of these festivals and
different stuff just certain people
walking around barefooted just smoking
hippie hippie life you know what I'm
saying of course you know they got the
streets I got family out there you know
I know that but it's just it's just a
good vibe City you know for sure man